and now independent senator Bernie
Sanders of Vermont discusses the eight
and a half hour speech he delivered on
the Senate floor on December 10th 2010
in that speech senator Sanders was
critical of President Obama's extension
of the Bush administration tax cuts for
top earners and diminished estate tax
rates as well as the disappearance of
America's middle class
[Applause]
thank you that was such a wonderful
introduction I wish you just could have
kept going and going it was sounding
very good
I want to thank Busboys and poets for
hosting this event and for all of the
great work you do thank you very much
and I want to thank everybody it's a
wonderful crowd and thank you all very
much for coming out let me talk a bit
about myself kind of by how I got to
where I am then I'm going to read a few
pages I'll read the introduction to the
book let's go on for seven or eight
hours after that they didn't tell you
that right and then we'll take some
questions and answers at four o'clock in
the morning
as you heard I am the longest-serving
independent and american congressional
history actually isn't work and you may
say well why is that why are you an
independent and the answer is pretty
simple it's that I believe that both
political parties are heavily dominated
by money to trust and I think that
millions and millions of working
families don't have the kind of voice
that they should be having in all levels
of government and I've chosen to be an
independent I caucus now with the
Democrats have always done that I began
my political career in Vermont by
running for the United States Senate on
a third-party ticket running against
Democrats Republicans and I received all
of 2% of the vote that was back in
roughly 1971 and not deterred I then ran
for governor of the state of Vermont the
same third plot equal Liberty Union
party and I went from 2 percent to 1
percent
not a kind of trajectory that we were
hoping but I may not be very bright but
I am persistent came back ran for the
Senate again in 1974 against my now
colleague Patrick Leahy he won I lost
but I got 4% of the vote in a 3-way race
so I saw the votes going up and then two
years later I ran for governor again we
have elections every two years in
Vermont and I got 6% at that point I
took the hints that maybe getting
elected to political office is not what
my life was going to be about and I went
about doing other things mostly doing
some writing working on historical
filmstrips and actually having a pretty
good time in 1981 you know how people
politicians always tell you that people
came up and said you should run for
office and actually in my case it was
true there were a number of friends who
said you know what we looked at the
election results sudden you did really
well in Burlington and if you're run in
Burlington which is largest city in the
state of run you might actually win so I
did and we put together a wonderful
coalition of unions and senior citizens
and women's advocates and environmental
advocates and the police officers came
on board and on election night we won by
14 votes defeating a five-term incumbent
which will probably go down in Vermont
history is maybe the major most
significant political upset of modern
Vermont history then we went to the
recount that I ended up winning by 10
votes I took office in 1981 with two
supporters on the City Council and the
rest were Democrats and Republicans who
are not particularly supportive in fact
they fired my secretary on the first day
I took office and I had to run the city
for the first year with my with the
previous mayor's administration it's
like Obama running with Bush's
administration it was a little bit
difficult but a year later we had
rallied the people and we
a number of seats in the City Council I
developed veto power and we began to do
some really exciting things in
Burlington after two years I ran for
reelection against Democrat Republican
one two years later ran against up
Republican won and then they combine the
parties and we won anyhow that was in
1987 1988 I ran for the United States
Congress and a lot of my liberal friends
said you shouldn't run because she'll be
a spoiler there's a strong Democrat
running against the strong Republican
you're gonna pull votes away on election
night the Republican one with 34%
I got 31% the Democrat got 19% two years
later I ran for that same seat in the
house and I won by 16 points that was
not a strong Democrat in serve there for
16 years ran for the United States
Senate in 2006 when Senator Jim Jeffords
who many of you know a very courageous
person chose not to run for reelection
he retired
we ran against the one of the wealthiest
guys in the state up until that point
the most anyone had ever spent in an
election in the state of Vermont was
about two and a half million
he spent 7 million we have to raise 5
million but we ended up winning by a
very strong vote up for reelection
in 2012 so that's my political history
let me now take you to why you're here
tonight we talked a little bit about the
book and read you from the introduction
on Friday December 10th 2010 I woke up
at my usual time had my usual breakfast
of oatmeal and coffee at the Dirksen
Senate building and then had a typical
daily discussion with some of my staff
at 10:30 a.m. I walked onto the floor of
the Senate and began a speech turned out
to be a very long speech a modern
version of the filibuster it went on for
8 and a half hours until 7 p.m. there
were several reasons why I went to the
floor for that speech first I had
promised to do everything I could to
oppose what I believed was a very bad
tax agreement between President Barack
Obama and the Republican leadership at a
time in this country
as a thirteen point eight trillion
dollar national debt and the most
unequal distribution of wealth and
income of any major country it seemed to
me totally absurd to provide hundreds of
billions in tax breaks for millionaires
and billionaires further by confirming
and this was the lame-duck session
before the Republicans took control of
the house further by confirming under a
democratic president a Democratic House
and a Democratic Senate the basic tenets
of Bush's horrendous trickle-down
economic theory this agreement was
laying the groundwork for more bad
decisions in the future
unfortunately I was absolutely right in
the takes us right through the Ryan
Republican budget of today second more
tax breaks for the very rich is only one
symptom of an economic and political
system that is grotesquely failing the
average American the simple reality is
that the middle class of America is
collapsing poverty is increasing and the
gap between the very wealthiest people
and everyone else is getting wider how
did this happen why did it happen what
can we do about it these are issues that
had to be talked about and talked about
in a way that is not often heard in
Washington over the over the 20 years
that I had served in the House and the
Senate
I had examined these issues issues far
too often ignored by the corporate media
and my colleagues in Congress from a
wide variety of perspectives now is an
excellent opportunity to bring them
together and to make the connections
what does it mean morally and
economically that in 2007 the top 1%
earned over 23 percent of all income in
this country more than the bottom 50% or
that the top 1% owns more wealth than
the bottom 90% given the enormous
political power that goes with this
concentration of wealth in terms of
lobbying capabilities campaign
contributions and media ownership is the
United States on its way to becoming an
oligarchic form of society with almost
all power resting in the hands of a tiny
few
what does it say about our economy and
the political choices we make about it
on Capitol Hill that today despite all
of the huge increases in productivity
and technology that we've seen in recent
decades a two-income family now has less
disposable income than a one income
family did 30 years ago why is it that
Americans today work the longest hours
of any people in the industrialized
world what is the correlation between
the United States having by far the
highest rate of childhood poverty of any
major country while we also have more
people in jail doesn't it make more
sense to invest in our kids than in jail
construction how does it reflect upon
our political and legal system when the
crooks on Wall Street who caused this
horrendous recession now earned more
money than they did before their banks
were bailed out by the taxpayers how
come none of them are in jail and what
does the financial reform bill mean when
three out of the top four
too-big-to-fail banks in this country
are now larger than they were before the
Wall Street collapse with assets of over
half the GDP of this country what does
it mean to the economic future of our
country that over the last ten years we
have lost 42,000 factories and millions
of good-paying manufacturing jobs and
that it is harder and harder to buy
products manufactured in America how
does it happen that CEOs of large
corporations boasts about the advantages
of outsourcing their production and jobs
to China but when hard times hit they
come running to US taxpayers for a
bailout and on and on and on so those
were some of the themes that I wanted to
talk about in my remarks that I wanted
to tie some of the dots together now
what does it feel like to stand and talk
1/2 hours when you can't leave the floor
eat or most importantly the question
asked the me time and time again
especially by the media
how come you to go to the bathroom how
is that and that's my secret
I'm not telling that's that they'll
never know and you do it all of this
with a national television camera on you
and the answer is my profound answer is
it's hard try it sometime
the after and interestingly enough the
after effect hit me a few days later
when I found myself very very tired
during the speech itself my legs began
to cramp up a bit my voice also became
pretty close when I walked on to the
floor I had no idea how long I would
stay there none at all when I was mayor
of Burlington in the 1980s I sometimes
gave speeches for as long as an hour and
that was it what I last three hours 5
hours 20 hours I really didn't know what
I was clear about in my own mind however
was that I wasn't going to read from the
phone book or sing songs and you'll be
happy to know I'm didn't sing any songs
believe me just eat up time I wanted to
speak for as long as I had something
relevant to say while I didn't have a
prepared script for the speech I mostly
worked off of previous speeches I had
given or articles that I had written and
occasionally excerpts from some books
that I had read I would read a few lines
or pages and go off from there twice
colleagues came to the floor and engaged
in what we call a colloquy I remain
grateful to Senator sherrod Brown and
Mary Landrieu for their support of my
effort but we also warned the good
readers of this book that it contains
some repetition hey what do you want
eight and a half hours it's gonna be
something and this is not an accident in
giving the speech I was more than a
whale that most people were not going to
be listening to it in its entirety I
suspected that most people were tuned in
for half hour or an hour and then move
on with their lives
I made it a point to keep returning to
my basic themes was I surprised about
the kind of attention that the speech
received
are you kidding the phones in both my
Washington Vermont offices never stopped
ringing
in Vermont every one of my eight staff
people did nothing else all day but
respond to calls thousands of calls and
emails the Senate television website
crashed because of the huge number of
people who wanted to watch the speech
live online and apparently c-span too
had an exceptional day according to the
New York Times my speech was the most
twitted event in the world on that day
what did the station never do it
most Twitter debate and some day I will
learn what Twitter is all about
ah there were front page stories in
newspapers all around the country in the
speech was covered widely in the
international media the number of people
who signed up his friends on my Facebook
page doubled the previous total in one
day and visits to my website went
sky-high some journalists even claimed
that Obama had an unscheduled impromptu
press conference with former President
Bill Clinton who defended the tax deal
in order to divert media attention away
from what I was doing on the Senate
floor just turned out Clinton was in the
White House there was no press and they
suddenly had a press conference and
captured a lot of attention despite my
best efforts in the hard work of many
other members of Congress we lost the
vote on the tax deal that President
Obama worked out with the Republicans a
very bad agreement was signed into law
was my eight and a half hour speech
worth the effort absolutely if this
country is going to move forward in a
new direction if we're going to save the
middle class and change our national
priorities we have got to cut through
the fog and office keishon of the
corporate mainstream media and start
focusing on the life-and-death issues
that working families really care about
the very strong response to my speech
tells me that there is a hunger all over
America for a discussion about economic
truths for a counter-attack on the
ferocious assaults that are taking place
against working families and for a
practical plan on how we can reverse the
obscene politics that favor the rich
over the middle class and the
disadvantaged in our nation if my speech
to help educate people about some of
these issues made them aware that
they're not alone in their
CERN's of their pain and pointed away to
the future it was well worth it that's
it
thank you
okay what I would love to do now is to
take any questions or thoughts that
anybody may have just be loud ma'am yes
thank you for everything you do what's
your advice on what we are what Congress
said senators should be doing about the
Citizens United decision does it have to
have a re to the Constitution or are
there better ways to do all right let me
just back that excellent question up
because perhaps everybody doesn't know
what the Citizens United decision is
about for many many years we have had a
disastrous campaign finance system which
clearly favors those people have a lot
of money and corporate interest against
those of us who do not year or so ago
our Supreme Court by a five-to-four
decision passed a disastrous absurd
decision called the Citizens United
decision and in their wind wisdom we
found actually five people in the same
room the only five people in America who
actually believe that a corporation is a
person there are five people in America
and they all have to be on the Supreme
Court at the same time and essentially
what that decision does is it says
through large corporations that you
being a person have First Amendment
freedom of speech rights and therefore
you are able to express your freedom of
speech by putting 30-second ads on
television telling the world how
terrible Bernie Sanders is or less
Feingold is or anybody else's and by the
way you can do that in secrecy you don't
even have to reveal who you are you can
come up with some phony name and phony
organization this is a disastrous
decision which makes a very bad campaign
finance situation much worse we saw it
in the last election you're going to see
a lot more of it essentially what's
going to happen is a handful of
billionaires and very
the corporate people are gonna sit
around the room and say okay you're
putting ten million at the Vermont
you're putting into New Hampshire you
got 20 million into California and for
these guys this is a small sum of money
to win a Senate seat or a House seat is
an arrhenius decision now what we have
tried to do on the floor of the house in
the Senate is at least pass some
legislation that would minimize minimize
the impact of citizens united so there
was legislation that was brought forth
which not shocking we got no Republican
support which said ok if I put an ad on
television attacking my opponent which
I've never done I'd never run a negative
ad I have to have my name on TV and say
I take responsibility for this and so we
said fine if you are a CEO of a
corporation who is paying for this ad
get your face up there and say you take
responsibility for this ad and we
thought that would discourage a lot of
corporations from doing that
second of all we wanted to make sure
that if a Chinese company company in the
United States owned significantly by
Chinese interests that they should not
be allowed to participate in American
politics thirdly what we wanted to do is
say okay if you utilize that then your
opponents somebody attacked me using
that process I would be able to get the
cheapest possible rates available to
respond any out we lost those votes we
couldn't get any Republicans what for
Republicans this is a very good Supreme
Court decision your question is should
we go forward with a constitutional
amendment in general I have to tell you
I'm not a great fan of constitutional
amendments you know every you know
people think you know everybody who has
a problem we need a constitutional
amendment to solve it that kind of
weakens what our Constitution is about
which is a pretty good document but on
this issue I think we can make the
exception to that rule so I do believe
that certainly a constitutional
amendment is one of the options that we
have in that amendment should simply say
that a corporation to everyone shock and
surprise is not a person last point that
I would say
on this issue we had a town meeting we
do a lot of town meetings in Vermont we
had one a couple of months ago a whole
lot of people out and been injuries many
of you know been injuries so Ben was
there a jury was there and Ben was very
funny he says you know I'm Ben I am a
person this is Jerry he's a person Ben
and Jerry's not a person and in a
nutshell that's about it
the idea that we give corporate
corporations First Amendment rights is
absurd yeah in my view you know global
warming is a huge huge issue and it
saddens me very much that today in the
Congress you have certainly a majority
of people in the house almost all
Republicans including intelligent people
who are willing to ignore virtually the
entire scientific community who tells us
global warming is real that global
warming is today today causing very very
serious problems and that those problems
are only gonna get worse in the future
you have the CIA telling us that in
terms of national security global
warming which can lead to Wars as people
around the world fight over limited
resources because of droughts floods
food shortages you know you've got the
CIA at the Defense Department the
agriculture all these organizations all
over the world saying it and yet the
anti science feeling on Capitol Hill is
such that we certainly at this
particular political moment are not
going to move forward on global warming
but to answer your question it's not
just global woman we could talk about
education we can talk
health care what are the answers and the
main point that I want to make to you is
the solution is not going to come inside
the beltway the solution is gonna come
in cities and towns all over this
country where ordinary people begin to
stand up and organize and get out on the
streets and say enough is enough I can
tell you you know without any fear of
contradiction that what goes on in
Congress is far far removed from the
reality of the lives of ordinary people
and that's true whether it's economics
that's true whether it's health care
what goes on in Congress is there's an
invisible wall infiltrated by lobbyists
and very powerful corporate interest who
shaped the whole discussion shape of the
debates you have a corporate media out
there which will talk about everything
in the world except issues that are most
important to ordinary people so global
warming is a huge issue and right now I
don't think there's anyone who thinks
we're gonna make serious advances in
addressing that what we may may may be
able to do is to get some investment in
energy efficiency and the state of
Vermont has done a very good job in that
area get some investments in sustainable
energies like wind solar geothermal
biomass and others get some investments
in public transportation but as you'll
notice for example just in this recent
CR that was passed in order to prevent
Republicans from shutting down the
government Obama had to give up on
billions of dollars in high-speed rail
high-speed rail so instead of investing
in public transportation and in rail we
have to cut back on that and I fear very
much that is this debate goes forward on
the budget you're gonna see more of
these cutbacks but to answer your
question and the other questions that
are on your mind we can turn this thing
around I believe that we can there are
very few people in America not located
inside the Capitol who believe that it
makes any sense
at all to give a trillion dollars in tax
breaks to the wealthiest people in this
country to cut the corporate tax rate at
a time when many corporations making
billions of dollars already pay nothing
in taxes and then having giving huge tax
breaks to people who don't need it cut
back on infrastructure cut back on the
needs of our children cut back to the
tune of hundreds of billions of dollars
on Medicaid voucherize Medicare very few
people believe that makes any sense at
all but our job is to cut through a
media which in many ways doesn't discuss
this issue take on the big money
interest who sponsor members of Congress
through large campaign contributions and
organize and educate and if we do that
we're going to win this fight to spend
money we think there are at least one
serious candidate out there and there
may be others but as of this point they
have not spent money against me
they're very Democrat a minor I'm
wondering this person increasing
conversation about race in this country
with birther movement and also
immigration laws they're passing and
there's also recent conversation about
wealth inequality are you finding a
conversation happening about racial
equality a good question I'll tell you
what we intend to do on that issue in
the area that I have some jurisdiction
there are some very frightening
statistics out there that we don't talk
enough about having to do that poverty
in America is in many ways a death
sentence and what I mean by that is if
you look for example you contrast in
terms of racial disparities say a rich
white guy who has access to good quality
health care disease prevention doesn't
live under an enormous amount of stress
because they'll have the income he needs
etc contrast that to a low-income black
person and you're gonna see a very
significant discrepancy and disparity in
longevity so I think you're gonna see
that and we're going to do a hearing and
get some studies done on that but the
fact of the matter is whether you're
black white Hispanic or whatever when
you are poor you're gonna live you're
gonna live a shorter lifespan and the
quality of your life will not be as good
as somebody else on I think those are
important issues to pound away
the debt ceiling raised more the Wall
Street banks were the heart and soul of
the Republican Party they they will suck
the most man and we've got to stand up
to the crazy Tea Party nuts and their
governors and a bunch they needed a lot
more than we cut necessary spending
as an excuse here let me that's a very
good question and I agree with you let
me back it up so that everybody knows
what we're talking about and let's be
honest about this and I I do a radio
show every Friday so we speak to a with
a fellow named Tom Hartman on of hearing
know Tom does a great job and we talked
to a couple of million people and every
week somebody raises this issue the
issue they raise is why is it that the
Republicans are so tough they don't
compromise and Democrats compromise all
of the time all right okay that's the
question they raise and I just look at
what's happened in the last year in
terms of what this book is about what
the Republicans said is okay there are
several million people whose
unemployment compensation is going to
expire but we don't want to extend
unemployment and unless you give us and
by the way that was a historical because
historically when unemployment was above
a certain level where we are right now
generally there was bipartisan support
for extending unemployment dropping us
we're not gonna do it and Obama and the
Democrats said well that's that's
terrible you got to do it you were going
okay we'll do it but this is what we
need from you we need to extend Bush's
tax breaks for the wealthiest people we
need to lower the tax rates on the
estate tax which go to the very very
very very wealthiest people top three
tenths of one percent going to bring
those things down and we are delighted
that you're going to divert and this was
not the Republicans idea they supported
it
in 20 billion dollars from the Social
Security Fund by doing a tax holiday on
the payroll tax for workers okay
hundred and twenty billion not going
into Social Work that was what they
demanded and essentially they got
everything that they wanted I thought
and that's why I was on the floor for
eight and a half hours that was a very
poor compromise he got a gift but that
was a very poor cut price which
Republicans got 90% of what they wanted
all right their threat was we are not
going to extend unemployment benefits
now a few weeks ago what was the
blackmail then the blackmail was if you
don't give us the cuts that we want
we're gonna shut down the government and
800,000 federal employees are not gonna
have a paycheck government services are
not gonna be available to people you
better give us what we want or we gonna
shut down the government well I voted
against that the Democrats fought back
they protected heads thought they're
protected planned parted but among other
things the program that I work very very
hard which is community health centers
which providing health care to 20
million people we got to increase that
investment so that in five years we're
gonna have 40 million people be able to
get primary health care dental care
low-cost prescription drugs mental
health counseling and they started
cutting back six hundred million dollars
off of that program millions of people
not gonna have access in the future to
community health center health care all
right so they're blackmail there was
we're gonna shut the government down and
Democrats fought back a little bit but
not enough now to your point we're in
part three of the movie and this time is
unless you make devastating cuts or lay
the groundwork for devastating cuts in
the future we for the first time in the
history of this great country are not
going to pay our debts we're going to
default on our debts we're gonna cause
an international financial crisis the
outcome of which nobody knows will it
lead to a world depression will it lead
to higher interest rates almost
definitely it will mean that for the
first time in the history
this country people who buy bonds for
the United States are gonna have second
thoughts about that Republicans have
said we're prepared to do that we're
prepared to do that unless you give us
what we want and this is like you know a
child having a temper tantrum you know
I'm gonna go nuts when companies in the
house unless you give me the candy or
I'm gonna burn down the place unless you
give me what I want well what the the
questioner suggests which is an
interesting point is that probably the
first group of people who are going to
be hit hardest by not raising the debt
ceiling will be Wall Street and I agree
with you I happen to think that our
friends on Wall Street who owned a good
part of the Republican Party will
probably not allow their employees to do
that so I think we have got to hang
tough because the point is it never ends
see these guys are very bold they are
very tough and they are very
irresponsible if I you know my
suggestion that the president is to say
to them to look them in the eye and to
say if you want to for the first time in
this country default on our debt if you
want to send the world into a financial
crisis you go ahead and do it and the
voters are going to hold you accountable
in the next election but we are not
going to keep surrendering on issue
after issue
[Applause]
okay say your question again below so
what do you foresee for the war on
terror that movie more dangerous for one
candidate I think you know I was as I
was coming back to Washington and I went
through the Burlington Vermont Airport
there are a lot of people who said
Bernie isn't this a great day and I
share that look you got a guy out there
and and one doesn't know in the last few
years how actively he involved it was
involved in terrorist movements because
he was kind of isolated and we'll learn
more about that I suspect within the
next few weeks but this is a guy who not
only on 9/11 but in other activities
killed thousands and thousands of
innocent men women and children and I
think the world is better off without
them now what I'm asked a Capitol Hill
by some of the media so what does this
mean about the war in Afghanistan and so
forth and so on
number one if anyone thinks that it was
Osama bin Laden single-handedly running
the international war on terrorism and
that with his demise suddenly everything
is going to be fine that is a naive
point of view that is not the case he
got cells all over the world and people
who want to do very very bad things I
think psychologically the taking him out
does have a positive impact I think more
importantly the growth of democratic
movements in the Middle East are very
very significant in terms of what it
means I'm asked about Afghanistan for
example my view didn't really change the
day before he was killed or the day
after we have been there for ten years
and I was in Afghanistan a couple of
months ago it is an enormous ly
complicated and difficult situation what
you have is a country which is terribly
terribly poor and undeveloped do you
know how much education the average
police officer in Afghanistan today has
zero functionally illiterate
and in fact I went to a place where an
international group Germany the United
States Ireland I think and others were
training police offices in Afghanistan
with the hope that they would leave with
a first grade or maybe even a third
grade education I visited a village in
the southern part of the country which I
suspect did not look a lot different
than it did over the last thousand years
the Taliban had been strong there we had
a nice little walk down the street with
a few senators and half the United
States Marine Corps strange sight but
you walk down you walk down the Main
Street there and you see these guys
selling vegetables or meat or whatever
it is I did not see one woman I did not
see one woman out on the street in
mid-afternoon they were all behind
closed doors they don't go out in public
so it is a copy I mean the goal here in
Afghanistan is to make sure that this
Taliban never again assumes power that
would be very bad for a wide variety of
reasons on the other hand after 10 long
years I believe that the time now is to
bring our troops home as quickly as we
possibly can
thank you for coming tonight to speak to
the people my question is you mentioned
multiple times the that Congress is
dominated by money interests what's your
opinion of the Israeli models and what's
your plan on achieving justice for the
Palestinian people and supporting
democracy I think the Israeli Lobby is
one of many many lobbies in Washington
and my hope is that the president will
work with Israel and the Arab countries
and people of all political persuasions
to develop what I suspect will be a
two-state solution and I think we have
to be aggressive it breaks my heart
because I've been to the Middle East to
see decent people on both sides and this
never-ending violence so I would hope
that the United States will play an
active role it is very difficult because
you got loonies on both sides trying to
tear it apart but I would hope that we
can bring people together so that this
never ending violence comes to an end
did you sell this I listen for mine I
didn't know him personally but he did
live in Vermont yes didn't know him
personally
Joyce eldest by the way was any of you
know who George tell this was he was a
oh did you he was kind of Yola ever hear
of I F stone salvus was it sentiment or
I think intellectually first on he was
one of these guys one of these
independent journalists who actually
read material and asked hard questions
that wrote a whole lot of books he was a
wonderful writer I think my memories
correct lived the last years of his life
in the state of Vermont but I'd never
met her I'm sorry to say Burlington did
he okay one more question I think
[Music]
[Music]
and by the way in my office remember I
live we came here how Guttman and Mike
Briggs and I'm like and I came here on
your subway but we don't have subways
like this in Vermont so to get to work
in Vermont on all over rural America you
drive and what happens is that you've
got millions of working people many of
whom have seen a decline in their wages
and now are paying four bucks or more
for a gallon of gas that's coming right
out of their paycheck and it's making
their very sorry economic situation
today even worse now here's what you got
with gas prices and we just back it up a
little bit to our friends on Wall Street
when you talk to people in Vermont or
anyplace else in this country people are
very very angry
there was a poll today I think it was a
Gallup poll and what the polls showed I
believe for the first time is that
people now believe that their kids are
gonna have a lower standard of living
than they do not that for the very first
time you know my parents never had any
money at all and there my dad worked his
whole life never made a whole lot of
money we lived in a small apartment but
if their dream was like everybody else's
dream every parent dreams that your kids
are gonna do better than you especially
if you start off without anybody so all
over this country now people saying you
know what my kid is gonna have less
education than I did my kid is gonna
earn lower wages than I did and there's
a lot of despair and anger all over this
country and if you would ask me one
issue one fact that symbolizes that is
people saw the crooks on Wall Street and
I use that word very advisedly the
crooks on Wall Street whose greed and
recklessness and illegal behavior
destroy our economy throw millions and
millions of people out of their jobs
people lost their homes people lost
their life savings when Wall Street
collapsed the stock
went down and now after they were bailed
out by the people of this country those
guys on Wall Street making more money
than they ever did before and not one of
these guys is in jail some kid throws a
brick through a window he goes to jail
these people destroy an entire economy
they end up making tens of millions of
dollars in compensation what all of that
is about is I think people beginning to
understand that these guys have so much
wealth and so much power that they are
untouchable that they can commit a crime
in mid daylight a terrible crime the
whole world is work is looking at it
destroying millions of lives and they
say ain't nothing you can do to me
because I own the United States Congress
you can't touch me I'm too powerful
you're not gonna throw me in jail so
what if I destroyed millions of lives
okay and that is in my view the real
reality now how does that deal with your
fine question about gas prices what
you're seeing right now is the theory of
oil prices is supply in demand right
that's capitalist economics when supply
is limited and demand is high prices go
up right we all learn that economics 101
so let me be the first to tell you right
now there is more oil supply in America
today than there was a year ago and on
top of that there is less demand in
America today than there was a year ago
more supply less demand what's supposed
to happen
price is supposed to go down they're
going off for more the reason for that
is our friends at Exxon Mobil and the
other large corporations many of which
by the way make you profitable than
aside what they have done is use the
excuse of unrest in the Middle East as a
reason to raise prices that's issue
number one but they're not alone and one
of the amusing things that's taking
place now is you're saying at the vision
to some degree between your companies
and Wall Street because the oil
companies are saying yeah we're greedy
we're selfish that's true but when I
the only ones what you're saying now is
speculation from Wall Street where these
Wall Street firms are bidding up oil
future prices they never used the
product they're just making money as
prices go up under the financial reform
bill passed a year ago we gave authority
to an arcane Commission that nobody in
the world has ever heard of called the
commodities future Trading Commission to
in fact end extreme speculation okay
that was what their job was they have
not done it and I have urged the
President to take action if these guys
don't want to do it get their
resignations but a whole lot of people
working people and the economy as a
whole are suffering while the oil
companies and Wall Street make a whole
lot of money but this would be a perfect
example of the powerlessness of Congress
to deal with very powerful entities who
are making you some money all right let
me thank you for the question let me
just conclude by thanking
[Music]
fight senator Sanders
we're doing great job what I wanted to
ask was do you know anything about the
quantitative easing that's going on like
approximately a trillion dollars was
being printed as we speak and I was just
wondering like where that money is going
to is going to be or what I'm just
worried about you know that's a good
politician let me pick up on the point
that you raised and go someplace else if
you're if you reminded me of something
and that is an issue that there's an
interesting to some degree coming
together of the left and the right and
that is the Fed in general okay now I
had serious doubts about the financial
reform bill the dodd-frank bill because
I didn't think about anywhere near far
enough I mean among other things as I
mentioned in the introduction we bailed
out these these huge financial
institutions because they were too big
to fail ie if they went down they would
take a good part of the economy with a
massive unemployment we had to bail them
out I didn't post the bail amount but my
colleagues did and then we find out that
after the bailout three out of the floor
are even larger today and a number of
economists believe that at some point
we're going to see a repetition of what
we saw a few years ago now what I got
into the bill working with this is
interesting
my right-wing friend Ron Paul and Paul
and I had worked together when we were
in the house and some issues but this is
an interesting coming together the right
in the left and that is what we wanted
to do is an audit of the Fed what I
ended up getting is a couple of things
didn't get everything I wanted but got a
lot and that is during the bailout all
of you remember there's a whole lot of
debate about the
the bailout which was my memories
correct about seven eight hundred
billion dollars and I voted against it
you know it ended up passing bottom line
is and the American people are outraged
by this with bailing out the people who
caused the problem with cetera et cetera
in any case if you want to know who
received that part money you go to the
US Department of Treasury go to their
website you'll find where every nickel
went it was pretty transparent at the
same time with very little discussion
our friends at the Fed Ben Bernanke and
company were lending out three trillion
dollars at very low interest rates and
as a member of the Budget Committee a
couple of years ago
Bernanke came before the committee and I
said mr. Bernanke my constituents people
of America want to know which financial
institutions got the money wait her to
go how do you get it and then I was very
clever and I said you have to be a
totally dishonest major financial
institution to get the money or could
you be an honest business person is
there an 800 number that you have to
call up he didn't think it was all that
funny in any case he said no I'm not
going to tell you and on that day we
introduced legislation to bring
transparency and we managed to get that
provision in the financial reform bill
and a couple of months ago the GAO did
the work and they did a good job and
they revealed where the three trillion
dollars went needless to say
every major financial institution in
this country got huge amounts of very
very low interest loans what was also
surprising you'll all be delighted to
know that at the same time as small
businesses all over this country can't
receive are not able to find affordable
loans every virtually every central bank
in the world including Arab central
banks Korean central banks also got a
bailout as well as wealthy families in
this country as well as large
corporations like General Electric okay
they all got
bail out and that was made public we
also learned that one of the Arab banks
that got a bailout was is now owned
majority-owned by Libya I mean that's
how crazy it is we are also about this
rant here is the Fed is an enormous ly
important agency enormously important of
which the American people know very
little so we're fighting to bring
transparency also you have bankers
sitting around the room deciding who got
these loans in what I consider to be
direct conflicts of interest and we have
a provision which I hope will be
implemented in July will the GAO will be
talking about conflicts of interest in a
sense people being part of a process in
which they benefit very handsomely but
the Fed is a huge issue and we need to
work much more aggressively on that
issue and the function of the Fed in my
view should be to protect the middle
class to create decent paying jobs in
this country and not just the bailout
very large financial institutions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the super protection II see that as part
of that bill President Obama's named
Elizabeth Warren to set it up is that
they didn't have any teeth at all in
white what do you think he didn't do
it's funny that you raised that issue
about Elizabeth I've known Elizabeth for
many many years
Elizabeth is one of the smartest people
that I have ever known she came to
Vermont to do some town meetings and
economics with me and what I love about
Elizabeth is she is able to take
difficult economic and financial
concepts and translate them into English
so that people know what she's talking
about
and I will tell you that I did more
lobbying to get Elizabeth appointed than
any other issue because I will tell you
this also when not long into the Obama
administration I can't remember six
months eight months after he was in a
number of well known number half a dozen
senators went to the White House to meet
with him and we said you know mr.
president we are concerned that you are
surrounding yourself with all the same
old Wall Street guys whether it's Larry
Summers or Geithner etc and so I was
determined that he gave his reasons why
it cetera but I was determined that
there at least I would do everything I
could to make sure there was least one
progressive voice there and then
certainly Elizabeth has that background
now there are a lot of Republicans who
are not enamored with Elizabeth I
certainly would have supported a recess
appointment
I hope Elizabeth will get the permanent
appointment which he does not have right
now but she is an extremely capable
person who is dealing with issues that
are of enormous enormous appoints you
know if you look at the Bible oh if you
look at any other religious tract you
know whether it's the Koran whether it's
whatever it may be
thus the the charging of high interest
rates usury is considered to be immoral
and the theory is that if you don't have
a lot of money and I'm lending you money
it is wrong to kind of get blood from a
stone
I shouldn't be charging you such
outrageously high interest rates today
in America we get calls on this all the
time you get working people who are
paying twenty five thirty percent
interest rates on their credit cards
that's usually that is no different than
loan sharking you know I don't know that
they go around breaking kneecaps now
like the you know gangsters used to do
it but they punished people if they
don't pay and you know this is an issue
I know the Lizabeth has been working on
and thinking about but it is certainly
something that I hope we could deal with
through her agency you know okay and
talk I think that's an excellent
question and I can tell you that there
are a number of people all over this
country and a number of us in the Senate
who feel the same way Harry Reid is a
good friend of mine I like Harry very
much his dilemma always is that he
believes that he has a job that we have
a job to pass legislation to address the
problems facing America which is what
his job is about that's what the leaders
job is I think that we could have and
should pick a particular issue now what
the gentleman is talking about is we
have seen a record level of
obstructionism on the part of the
Republicans from the day after Obama was
elected they made it very clear you want
to accomplish something you ain't gonna
do it in the old days the old it was
for people to require the 60 votes for
you to have to break the 60 votes to get
cloture that was very very rare now on
almost any significant piece of
legislation they have demanded 60 votes
which is very very difficult to get just
one example during the health care
reform debate I introduced legislation
which would call for a Medicare for All
single-payer program and by the way I
hope that my state of Vermont is going
to lead the nation in that direction
we're working harder in any case I had
no illusion no illusion at all that this
was gonna win
no way I mean I thought we'd get
somewhere between five and ten votes but
I thought it important to get it out
there we've been the first time in
history that a single-payer program had
a voter on the ledge I got up there to
introduce the legislation and a
Republican colleague refused what you do
when you introduce legislation you say I
ask that the bill be considered as read
in other words you don't have to read
the whole bill this guy got up and said
my objective I want the whole bill read
long bill would have required 16 hours
of reading that is called and this bill
wasn't gonna win lucky to get 10 votes
but that's called obstructionism and
that's what they have been doing so I
agree with you I think we should have
picked an issue with Republicans
objected and let the American people
shut it down and let the media and the
American people focus on that issue and
if it takes a week it takes 2 weeks 7
days a week 24 hours a day let's do it
that would have been my preference and I
think the preference of some other
people
[Applause]
he's getting a little tired it's not
going to be another historic this is
truly the last question for the evening
I think all of you for coming out
well senator Sanders on you caucus with
the Democrats view identifies an
independent which I think in this day
and age is there's a great deal of
respect I I know that a lot of us here
in 2008 though word on the street was
hope and changed we were both for a
scene change in Washington politics and
sad to say it didn't come to pass the
way a lot of us did hope and I do
believe that there was a lot of ill
feeling over the year 2000 over the
native so-called theatre spoiler effect
and but I think I'm not alone in saying
looking at the way the extremists on the
far right have mentioned cancer the
conversation of those of us on the Left
have been left behind have been ignored
do you see the place for more than any
candidates for third party hands which
was he supported possibly as President
Obama continues to listen more as
critics on the right in this personal
left voting for a primary challenger in
2012 or voting for a third party you'll
allow me not to answer that specifically
only in this sense I mean because it's
you know anybody can run for any office
they want to run if I am if you're
asking me am I going to be involved in
that process no I'm not but here's what
I think
and I speak with some knowledge about
this because I am an independent I have
run on third parties and I'm the longest
serving independent in the congressional
history I think he got to be judicious
about it in other words I think in the
real world in the real world I mean you
could say I don't give a damn about
anything I'm gonna run for office and I
don't really care if you have a
right-wing Republican or right-wing
Senate and I really don't care
I'm running on principle and that's fine
I can understand that I disagree with
that I think however all over this
country there are opportunities for
progressive candidates to run and he
want to run outside of the Democratic
body I think if if the context is right
do it I did it I mean I was telling you
the 1988 I was told not to run because I
would be a spoiler it turns out I got a
lot more votes than the Democrat
than that so I think you gotta use you
gotta be due judicious about it and I
think also whether you choose to run
within the Democratic body or outside of
the Democratic Party
this I do believe you know I think that
the Republican agenda of tax breaks for
billionaires and savage cuts on the
needs of the middle class and working
families these guys really do want to
take us back to the 1920s where you know
if you were old and you were poor you
are on your own no health care for you
didn't matter if you were a kid didn't
matter workers had no rights do not
underestimate these are serious people
then I've foolin around they want to
take us back for the 1920s to an
oligarchic form of society where power
rested with a handful of very very
wealthy people I think that their views
that ideology is way way way out of
touch with what the American people
believe now one of the problems that we
have is you've got a media which does a
pretty poor job which is you know also
corporately on to a large degree not to
mention a television station which is
there's completely so you got that
problem but I think whether you're
running within the Democratic Party or
not I beg of you do not become cynical
do not give up on the political process
we are fighting for not only our
generation but for our kids and our
grandchildren I have six grandchildren I
take their future seriously okay and we
do not have the option of not fighting
we can beat these guys we can beat them
nobody believes in their ideology nobody
thinks that children in America should
not have health care whether workers
should not have lights
they are a fringe movement and if the
Democrats have the guts to go out to
organize if we work together on this
thing we can beat them and beat them
badly but but we can't do it
I know that it's hard look I mean I just
I know people in my state all over this
country are disappointed I'm
disappointed
all right but you can't give up we got
to raise that progressive agenda make it
loud and clear
organize people around that educate your
neighbors because what we are fighting
for is so so and what it is the future
of this country so I just want to thank
Busboys and poets for hosting this thank
you so much you're a treasure thank you
all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
for more information on senator Bernie
Sanders visit his website sanders dot
senate dot govt